en fait on était en cours d'histoire au
bout de deux heures de cours
dans leur création mais lorsque
mais en fait il y a une surveillance qui
vient de nous dire que on avait un
soi-disant un exercice de sécurité qu'il
fallait rester
seul c'est un truc une minute voire 2
minutes avec notre
PDF rumeurs qui commençait à tourner on
a un élève
dans sa prof sa mère et professeur et
donc il a appelé
les élèves ont ensuite été confinés
plusieurs heures dans leur salle de
classe vont pouvoir rentrer chez eux
dans des conditions très particulières
[Applaudissements]
à midi mais sans sans qu'on puisse
sortir en fait il y a une des trois CPE
donc la CTS collège 4e 3e qui est venu à
la place et qui nous a dit que on
pouvait sortir mais elle m'a donné un
chemin de vie bien précis qu'il fallait
il fallait faire un détour parce que il
il y avait
[Applaudissements]
on est rentré chez nous
décrit comme une professeur incroyable
et très à l'écouter
espagnol il a la nature elle adorait
l'infini
qui adorait faire
alors Mathis qui est avec nous toi tu es
un ancien élève de cette professeur
d'espagnol qui était assassiné ce matin
et quand tu as appris la nouvelle
ça a été un choc parce que nous à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz à saint Thomas on
n'avait jamais eu de choses comme ça qui
s'était passé on n'a jamais vécu
d'événements comme ça et donc moi je
l'ai appris par l'intermédiaire de mon
frère qui était en cours et donc
il m'a dit que la classe était
exactement comme le témoignage c'est à
dire qu'on qui sont venus on leur a dit
il t'a raconté le et il m'a envoyé un
message pour me dire ce qui se passait à
peu près et donc moi je suis venu tout
de suite en bas de saint Thomas au
parking et c'est là qu'on a vu les
militaires la police on a vu tous les
enfin j'ai vu tous les parents d'élèves
aussi qui étaient rassemblés et
forcément on n'avait pas le droit
d'entrer personne de sortir donc après
l'attente a été très longue mais
quand les élèves sont sortis il y en
avait plein d'élèves en pleurs d'autres
qui tremblaient et ça a dû être vraiment
terrible pour ceux qui étaient en classe
avec elle même pour tous les autres
qu'il avait au quotidien parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un lycée très très
tranquille voilà en principe oui on n'a
jamais eu de choses moi pendant mes
années j'ai fait collègues et c'est
là-bas on n'a jamais eu aucun événement
de ce style tout allait bien enfin les
profs étaient sympathiques leur but est
de nous emmener vers le haut de nous
faire réussir donc on n'a jamais eu de
gros problèmes avec eux ou c'est cadeau
très chic là-bas
et soit on pense forcément à cette
professeur et à ses proches et toi tu as
eu cette professeur quand tu étais en
troisième en quatrième quatrième
d'accord et c'était une prof passionnée
elle aimait son boulot elle voulait tout
faire pour qu'on réussisse elle était
pas très sévère elle était pas très
autoritaire avec nous elle était
vraiment une prof idéale quoi enfin je
sais pas si ça se dit mais vraiment une
très bonne prof et c'est celle qu'on
voulait avoir quoi en quelque sorte
c'est vraiment
j'ai que des très bons souvenirs à
laquelle et voilà on n'oubliera jamais
alors les élèves bien sûr sont très très
choqués on a écouté un dernier sonore de
de cet élève qui n'a pas eu accès à une
cellule psychologique il est très très
marqué
[Applaudissements]
directement à la scène et tout on a mal
vraiment pour ceux qui étaient à l'étage
et les classes voisines pour l'instant
c'est rien mais je pense sûrement que
demain matin on aura des gens qui vont
venir nous parler ça ça sûrement une sur
Youtube pour tout le monde je pense
quand même je trouve normal qu'on doit
prendre du temps avant de pouvoir
comprendre
de travailler